Jetzt gerade ist die spannendste Zeit,
um auf der Welt zu sein.
Noch nie in derMenschheitsgeschichte wurde so vielerlebt, so viel erfunden, erforscht, hinterfragt und verändert.
Noch nie gabes so viel Wissen und die Möglichkeit,
so viel über unser Universum, unsere
Umwelt und uns selbst zu erfahren.
Jetzt gerade ist aber auch die Zeit,
in der es vielleicht die meisten
Herausforderungen gibt. Noch nie gab es so
viele Menschen auf unserer Erde. Noch nie
so viele Krisen, so viele Probleme,
die dringend gelöst werden müssen.
Deswegen ist jetzt gerade die wichtigste
Zeit. Wir müssen Lösungen finden,
Entscheidungen treffen und Wissen vermitteln.
Und genau deswegen gibt es Doktor Whatson.
Wir sind ein unabhängiges Team aus
Wissenschaftsbegeisterten und wollen mit euch
zusammen über die spannendsten, die wichtigsten
und die genialsten Ideen unserer Zeit sprechen.
Wir wollen euch erklären, wie die Welt
funktioniert. Welche Zukunftstechnologien
unser Leben verändern und welche
Forschungsergebnisse was zu bedeuten
haben. Wir wollen das Wissen dieser Welt an euch
weitergeben. Einfach verständlich, in spannenden
Videos mit Mind-Blow-Faktor. Jede Woche, hier auf
Doktor Whatson. Bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric.